hello everybody and welcome back to
another elden ring lore hunting video
these types of videos are where i just
kind of go over some findings that i
have found in the world of elden ring or
some comments that you guys have left
that i would like to go over and kind of
discuss with everybody none of the lore
that i discuss in these videos is
supposed to be a hundred percent
accurate even though that's what we're
going for all the time is to be accurate
however these videos are just kind of
meant to start a conversation to start a
discussion that can possibly lead to
different types of theories or
connecting certain lore elements to
other elements of the game that you guys
find or i find and we discuss in the
video and down in the comments below
first thing i want to go over is thank
you all for 3 000 subscribers this is a
brand new channel that's gotten all of
those subs just from eldon ring content
i really really appreciate it so just
thank you guys i'm gonna keep making
other ring videos if you keep watching
them keep liking the video keep
subscribing and i'll keep making them i
appreciate it the second thing is that
this video is going to be a continuation
of another video i made a couple weeks
ago called what are they hiding under
stormville castle where i found some
really interesting stuff and i found a
connection to what i found here as well
as in the roots of the erd tree
specifically talking about this guy
right here so at the time a couple weeks
ago i had no idea who this was what this
is it's just this disgusting piece of
flesh that that bleeds when you hit it
and thanks to all of you we can now
pretty much 100 confirm that this is a
husk of godwin the golden so i'm sure a
lot of you guys know this part of the
lore already where ronnie the witch was
behind the knight of black knives and be
rid of her bind to the golden order and
the two fingers but to do that she had
to also kill another demigod at the
exact same time so she stole a fragment
of the rune of death from malakath and
used it on herself and on godwin ronnie
destroyed her body while godwin's spirit
was destroyed i'm pretty sure that's all
really common knowledge now if not there
you go but i'm going to go over some
more connections to godwin in this video
so first thing that a ton of you guys
brought up was this blood stain that's
just sitting right next to the husk of
godwin here when i originally came into
this area i thought this was just some
random bloodstain where some player fell
down this giant ladder or something i
have no idea but actually i'm playing
offline right now so it's really weird
that this is here and this is what we
find so this is roger and he's clearly
being oh my god that's really disturbing
i i haven't seen that in a bit uh he's
clearly being possessed or rooted up by
something my guess is that he was kind
of taken over by these roots right here
now at least in this playthrough that
i'm recording this on right now
raju is dead he died to whatever
infected him
right here down below stormville castle
so let's go over some item descriptions
that we found that link to godwin the
golden first up we have the golden
epitaph a sword made to commemorate the
death of godwin the golden first of the
demigods to die infused with the humble
prayer of a young boy o brother lord
brother please die a true death now this
is likely mykola saying these words to
his brother godwin just to experiment
really quick what happens when i do this
absolutely nothing okay i had to test
that real quick because since the elden
ring shattered the rune of death no
longer exists in the greater will in the
lands between within the elden ring
nobody dies a true death when they die
so i'm not sure who made this weapon but
at least mikola wanted his brother
godwin to die a true death so what i was
just showing you guys was a husk of
godwin the golden and what he has become
after being infected with the rune of
death i believe this to be the true form
of godwin now his body being completely
mangled up to a point of where he's
completely unrecognizable but it seems
like this is where godwin actually rests
it's not like there's anything inside of
this husk of his because his spirit is
completely dead but his body still
exists and is infecting the roots of the
herd tree so i'm assuming what we found
under stormville castle is just a husk
of what his infection has spread to who
knows maybe his body or his eyeballs
that we can see right here can traverse
through different husks in the world i
think we're gonna find a lot more about
this in future dlc of elden ring at
least i hope so because this is so
interesting next i would like to take a
look at the remembrance of the lich
dragon fortisacks that reads after
godwin the golden became the prince of
death the ancient dragon fought long and
hard against the death within its
companion the last victory was never
achieved and its only reward was
corruption so this basically tells us
that godwin the golden was friends with
the lich dragon fortisacks from
different sources that i've read it
seems like godwin the golden was one of
the most beloved demigods of all of the
kids of the golden order and he was used
to fight dragons that's speculation not
confirmed but that's what i've read in a
lot of different sources we can confirm
their companionship from the incantation
spell death lightning that reads it said
that this golden lightning was wielded
by godwin who befriended for the sax so
we could pretty much completely confirm
that fortisacks and godwin were friends
now in this playthrough i've already
fought for sax i've already done fia's
complete questline it's kind of
interesting that her body always lays
here it never just goes away but it's
very cool that florida sacks was just
inside of godwin's spirit brain
somewhere inside of godwin where he was
trying to fight off the corruption of
death and wound up being corrupted
himself kind of sucks it seems like
godwin was a really cool dude now a lot
of godwin's story has a ton to do with
fia the death bed companion at the end
of her questline she wants us to do one
thing which is to become elden lord and
then use the mending rune of the death
prince to embed the principle of life
within death into the golden order this
completely goes against the golden order
because like it says here the golden
order was created by confining destin
death thus this new order will be one of
death restored and a very interesting
fact that i did doing the gold mass
quest line was getting the mending rune
of the perfect order which is a rune of
transcendial ideology which will attempt
to perfect the golden order now we
learned from roger that there was some
sort of imperfection within the golden
order this pretty much confirms what
that is which is the instability of the
ideology of the golden order itself
which can be blamed upon the fickleness
of the gods no better than men that is
the fly in the ointment basically saying
that the demigods of the golden order
the demi-god kids always just left they
were fickle they kind of changed it up
all the time and went on to believe and
do different things that's the
imperfection of the golden order which
is a pretty interesting find it kind of
seems like godwin got the short end of
the stick on what ranny had to do to
complete her destiny because if randy
truly wanted to break her tie in her
empyrean flesh with the two fingers in
the golden order she had to either give
up both her body and spirit or she had
to give up one so she had to give it to
another as well and godwin just so
happened to be that other half and then
honestly it feels like people like fia
are just sort of taken advantage of the
fact that godwin is still technically
alive but he has just no spirit in this
disgusting twisted up body of his now
it's a lot of interesting information
that i think a lot of people out there
can decipher and come up with theories
on their own thank you guys for watching
the video i really appreciate all the
support recently have a great rest of
your day and i'll see you in the next
video peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you